The joe rogan experience, you know,
I dunno what we're speaking of,
but we need to talk about Kanye just,
oh,
Jamie's got crazy Kanye conspiracy
theories. Slash. Theories.
Well, first, so first of all, he's
like, he came out for Trump recently,
sort of,
he wore a make America great again hat on,
but he also called Trump a bald thief.
Why suddenly too?
He did. Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah, he
called them balled crook or a Paul.
Kanye is a lunatic.
Yeah.
So I could care less what he
says about Amy loves saying,
Jamie Sleeps with a picture of Kanye.
I'll stop if you believe that
she came to believe that.
Come on people believe everything you
were saying about me. It's not a, it's I,
it's a pendant with a picture
with his picture on in it. Jamie.
A big fan of two things.
Nuclear Weapons and Trump. He's,
yeah, he loves nuclear bombs and
he loves physics class. Yeah.
So Trump before, here's, here's
what, here's what I like.
I, well, Connie is a lunatic,
but I do like Candace Owens who was also
new on the scene and my Fox News world.
You love that. I love you love
conservatives and Candace is just like,
she walked in from work the other day
and I was like started listening to Fox
News is on and of course I'm watching.
I'm like, who the hell is this?
You Say Fox News is on of course,
because Fox News just blaring propaganda
through your house all the time.
Do you ever switch it up?
Like have like CNN on the back,
nine Fox News on in the living
room. I watch it. I do watch CNN.
Alex Jones says 200 1:30 PM to watch
him for wars. Exclusive on Kenya's.
Candice and Kanye like exclusive.
I don't, it didn't happen.
It's like alive. What is he going
to say? Featuring canvas and Kanye.
So I need a lump them in together.
But he's he talking about them.
Everyone thought they were
going to be on this show to you.
Oh, it didn't happen for a wars
exclusive. He probably called them Kanye.
It's Alex Jones. I could
care less that Connie says. I
like what canvas says. Well,
Jamie thinks that all this wackiness
with Candace Owens and Kanye is really
Kanye just getting people hyped up
about the release of his new album,
which will be out in a few months.
So he's getting people fired up.
You think that's what's happening Jamie?
Yeah, there's a internet
conspiracy that's been like,
not proven because it can't be proven yet,
but uh,
there's a long Twitter thread and a few
like reports now blogs or magazines if
you will,
that sort of lead to like an Andy Kaufman
s type performance art piece that he's
doing.
Maybe bring up a conversation about some
of these topics he's actually talking
about. Or maybe we'll find
out when his album comes out.
If Kanye is doing performance art,
then what's the point? Here's the,
here's the problem is a certain amount
of him that is undeniably insane.
And um,
you've seen that,
like that thing that Jimmy Kimmel
mocked where you had that little kid,
he used to do little kids saying things
that Kanye said and like he would have
like, really? Yeah. Like he
would have little kids say
exactly by the way, hate him.
He's a nice guy. No, you meant to be
like him. I want to go. I, he's like,
why he cries about hunting.
Okay.